I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man Avengers infinity war is by
far the most ambitious movie we've ever
made it really is the start of the
culmination of at this point nineteen
Marvel Cinematic Universe films and will
feature almost every hero that we've
introduced into the universe all in one
movie one of the great joys of reading a
Marvel comic is flipping through a
spider-man comic and suddenly the hope
appears that is great fun and up to that
point it had never been done in a movie
before which is why ten years ago Sam
Jackson walked into Tony Stark's living
room and said you're part of a bigger
universe you just don't know it yet and
now here we are 10 years later and
everybody knows it let's talk about this
plan of yours I think it's good except
it sucks so let me do the plan and that
way it might be really good Wow we look
at all the different aspect ratios but
the pure form and the biggest form with
all the information is that IMAX frame
so there are things happening above and
below frames that if you're not seeing
I'm actually not seeing it we filmed the
cool thing once we've been in
Cumberbatch being Doctor Strange and
pushing the frame up what's fun with
infinite war is that's entire film
because when you have a storyline this
big and when you have the promise of a
culmination of all these different
storylines we wanted to tell it in a big
format possible
is near the IMAX screen has a different
height than a traditional movie screen
those that go to an IMAX theater will
see a much taller view of the image so
if you're in a traditional theater it's
gonna be narrower if you're an IMAX
theater it's gonna be expanded there's
more information in the frame there's
more storytelling to look at you see
more the character you see more of their
powers see more of the scale in the film
such as presented on a much grander
frame than the moment you do we got one
advantage he's coming to us we have what
thinnest ones so that's what we use we
have characters in this movie like Fano
started taller than normal human beings
are when you're framing those kind of
characters in the same frame it can
become really challenging with a with a
normal aspect ratio to like hold those
height differentials and a single frame
and it forces you into certain angles
and certain types of frames and lenses
and you having that extra verticality
like Joe was talking about it gives us a
wider range of how we frame and how we
shoot these characters how we present
them in the same frame together when you
sit in IMAX theater it takes up your
entire field of vision and you begin to
forget that there even our borders and
your in the entire movie and as a
filmmaker that's what you want the
audience to experience having more
information having technology at our
disposal is just storytelling freedom
and having the enormity of the frame
that IMAX delivers just gave Joe and
aunt more room to tell their story it
really is the difference when we go
through and work on the movie you can
hear an audible gasp in the visual
effects room where everybody goes and
you suddenly see the whole thing it
comes down to the difference between
watching a frame and experiencing the
world
I hope they remember
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]